I wanted to observe the early universe
and its infant State I wanted to do that
for two reasons I've always been
fascinated by the biggest possible
questions I'm Jewish but I grew up as a
Catholic young man I was an altar boy in
the Catholic church and never had a bar
mitzvah I was interested in the origin
of the universe trying to know if God
existed and trying to understand our
place in the cosmos and I didn't care
about kind of the stamp collecting
aspects of life I didn't care about
parties and all sorts of other things
status Sports I just want to understand
Math Science and use my telescope those
were my real Fascinations as a young man
my father was a great scientist his name
is James ax I don't have the same last
name as mother and father got divorced
and I live with my stepfather who became
my stepfather and he adopted me and I
lost touch with my biological father for
many many years for 15 years I didn't
see him and in that period of time I
knew he was a great scientist he was a
great mathematician he was the youngest
tenured professor of mathematics at
Cornell in their history he went on to
have a great career and I didn't see him
I kind of had this rivalry with him
Jordan and you can psychologically
diagnose it as you like but just as a
boy might want to be a better football
player or wrestler than his father I
want to be a better scientist than him
as great a scientist as he was he never
won the Nobel Prize and I realized I
could you know kind of one-up this old
man who had abandoned me and my older
brother decades earlier and I could do
what he did not and best of all doing
the most fun thing I could possibly
imagine building telescopes and studying
the biggest picture topics so this
became my obsession
foreign
thank you